yes if you're 30 and you have 2100
you're
really doing uh fantastic so
definitely you can um
you can become you even have potential
to become a grand master
and but definitely you have potential to
become a title player i think if you're
thirteen and that raining you're gonna
you're gonna go far i do not give
trainings i
am uh my chess understanding is
too little and my
on my other i have too many other things
to do
i try to work on my own chest
understanding
yeah i always liked watching them um
penny that they um let it stop
or maybe they will return at some point
who knows okay so we're playing some
kind of weird dutch
defense here i tried to learn into the
karo khan at first he declined
sadly and now we're playing some kind of
dutch defense here
i tried to win a piece here but it was
spotted by my opponents
always um
always a bad feeling when your opponent
sees your tracks
okay so queenie two how do you play here
i guess i'm slightly worse
i don't know how to um player like i
don't really
see c5
no maybe a6
let's play a6
my favorite web series i thought i said
already yesterday but um
dexter game of thrones prison break
breaking bad all good stuff
i'm sure i'm forgetting some which is a
bit annoying but yeah some good i
watched
no i do not watch japanese on him
i don't even know how to pronounce on
and i'm anime
so there you go i think by my
pronunciation you can tell me that you
can tell
that i'm not an expert
okay let's go b4 dc i want bc and after
the
exchange operation wait take stakes
takes
yeah i promoted check wait dexterous
season nine is coming what i didn't
really like the ending of uh dexter so
really they're making a whole new season
wow
ah okay let's
let's play bishop b7 here
very funny position here in fact we got
all the pieces on the board so it's
quite a sharp position
and bishop on h2 is not too great
but uh of course everything is still up
in the air here
not sure why he's giving me that pawn
all the time
i refuse to take it twice but i
won't refuse twice
shaman king i've never i've watched
lupine yeah that was nice waiting for um
to um
waiting for a new season there that was
quite fun
yes i am trying to read all chats um so
it's not so easy
but i'm i'm trying my best to read the
chats guys so um definitely
um be active there and i will um i will
be uh
in touch with chad of course charlie
booth or sean mendes
no real preference there
hello jordan i started four months ago
and i'm 1800 is that good yes you're
doing fantastic
go on keep it up so queen takes d5 here
would be a nice
positional sacrifice if it's um
but the problem is it loses a queen but
um there was something to be said for it
now i have really nice position going
for me
but still have to finish it off i'm
gonna go
g5 attack
go go go
okay that did not sound very dangerous
but his position is dangerous
g4 is coming and um
pawn up king f1 some kind of prophylaxis
or
freeing up the square for um the
the the knight but knight e4 now is
hitting um
queen and pawn we'll go
not even take it because i like um
torturing
every sadistic guy i am queen takes h2
is
good but i like this oh shoot my queen
oh it's checkmate what luck by me
i was just playing for this trick point
is he cannot even go to g2 because
bishop is on visa